the biden administration is nearing a
decision on student loan forgiveness an
issue that could affect millions of
americans and influence the coming
midterm elections
no matter what he ends up deciding biden
will be taking a major political risk
whether he decides to cancel large
amounts of student debt ten thousand
dollars worth of student debt or no
student debt at all it's going to anger
somebody and it's unclear whether that
somebody will be voting in november
biden has already ruled out for giving
fifty thousand dollars per student
borrower but has shown support for
legislation eliminating up to ten
thousand dollars in debt
still some legal experts and economists
say the administration needs a plan that
will stand up to legal challenges and
avoid contributing to record high
inflation rates as the debate over mass
student loan forgiveness continues what
are some of the key challenges
complicating biden's final decision
so rather than taking a stroke of the
pen and saying
all student debt is canceled biden has
instead used existing powers that the
federal government already has for
disabled borrowers for students who have
been defrauded for people who work in
public service as biden considers
whether to cancel debt on a mass scale
he has to juggle legal political and
economic fallout that might result from
that kind of decision one concern tied
to mass student loan forgiveness is
inflation
some economists warn debt cancellation
could intensify price pressures at a
time when inflation is at its highest
level in 40 years with an 8.6 annual
rate as of may
there are worries that canceling student
debt on a mass scale could exacerbate
problems with inflation because it would
give borrowers more spending power which
they would then use to purchase goods
and drive up inflation further in a
supply-constrained economy in order to
prevent that the byte administration is
looking at these lower levels of debt
forgiveness which would be less
inflationary depending on what
forgiveness policy biden lands on the
price tag could range anywhere from 321
billion for ten thousand dollars per
borrower all the way up to about 1.6
trillion dollars if all student debt is
cancelled eliminating all federal
student debt could raise inflation by
0.37 to 0.5 percentage points
that's according to the committee for a
responsible federal budget an
independent nonpartisan nonprofit
but some economists say a smaller scale
forgiveness program could have less of
an impact on inflation rates
biden is also considering limiting the
program to borrowers who make less than
125 000 a year according to white house
officials they're considering putting an
income threshold in place so that only
lower income borrowers will benefit as
opposed to higher income borrowers who
may still have student loans but are in
a much better position to pay them off
if you canceled ten thousand dollars
worth of debt and especially if you
included an income threshold the effects
on inflation would be pretty negligible
according to most economists
still some economists say there are
long-term inflationary risks
in the long term
student debt forgiveness could
exacerbate inflationary pressures by
having borrowers treat loans essentially
as grants because they expect those
loans to ultimately be forgiven by the
federal government it could also push up
the price of higher education because
colleges could pretty truthfully say to
their prospective students it doesn't
really matter what our tuition costs
because the federal government is just
going to forgive that debt in the future
anyway
in a statement a spokesperson for the
u.s department of education said our
overall goal is long-lasting change that
reduces indebtedness and makes college
more affordable including through
rulemaking
legal challenges may also complicate the
final decision
according to a legal analysis prepared
by obama's former top education
department lawyer biden could be on
shaky legal ground if he were to pursue
broad-based student debt cancellation by
executive action
lots of people including democrats think
that they don't have the authority to
cancel debt on a mass scale outside of
an existing program like the income
based repayment program
and if he just does it by executive
action president biden runs the risk
that this could get overturned in court
especially by a supreme court that tilts
conservative
biden has long been skeptical of using
his executive authority to wipe away
student loan debt i don't think i have
the authority to do it by signing
still those who are financially tied to
the student loan industry may be in a
position to sue the administration
like loan servicing companies and
investors that own securities backed by
student loans so for instance the
companies that service these loans could
potentially sue because they would be
servicing fewer loans because some of
those loans would be forgiven entirely
people who hold investments that are
based on the debt held by these
borrowers could also sue because their
underlying investments would be affected
if biden chooses to go the regulatory
route there could be other bureaucratic
challenges
the issue for biden if he goes the
regulatory route is that they haven't
really started a rulemaking process for
mass debt cancellation which means that
any future debt cancellation on a mass
scale that went through that process
would be very far down the road because
of how long the rulemaking process takes
implementing a large new government
program may come with logistical hurdles
too for instance a wider forgiveness
policy could require millions of
americans to file paperwork detailing
their income potentially creating a
massive backlog
cancelling debt on this wide of a scale
would be a major logistical lift for the
federal government they would need to
verify people's incomes if they're
putting an income threshold in place
they need to make sure that they're
cancelling the right loans and not
canceling others and all of that would
take a significant amount of time and
it's unclear how fast they would be able
to implement it and whether that would
even happen
in biden's first term
about 40 million borrowers hold about
1.6 trillion dollars in federal student
debt making student debt forgiveness a
potent issue ahead of november's midterm
elections and a pause on federal student
loan payments is set to expire at the
end of august just as campaign season
gets underway if democrats lose one seat
in the senate they will have lost the
majority and if they lose more than a
handful of seats in the house of
representatives they will have lost the
majority there as well which could badly
damage biden's chances of enacting
anything serious in the remaining two
years of his first term
some democrats are urging biden to go
big hoping that a sweeping debt
forgiveness plan can motivate voters who
will decide which party controls
congress
other democrats worry such a move would
alienate voters who don't currently have
student debt or never did
at the same time republicans broadly
oppose any type of mass forgiveness
policy
40 million people is a major portion of
the american electorate making their
student debt payments when they resume
is going to take a significant chunk of
their income every month so it's
something that voters are keenly aware
of if they hold student debt and if they
previously paid off their loans or never
had loans to begin with they might look
at debt cancellation policies and say
well that wasn't around when i was
paying for college
as millions of borrowers await a final
decision the biden administration is
weighing the long-term impacts of a wide
scale student loan forgiveness program
while progressives in congress would
love for congress to do something on
student debt forgiveness they understand
that those votes might not be there and
that nothing is likely to happen in
congress at least right now so it is up
to the biden administration to make
these tough calls
[Music]
you